the famous live streamer ice poseidon
just scammed his followers for up to
half a million dollars and i'm gonna
prove it he personally profited three
hundred thousand dollars by stealing
money out of a crypto scheme that he set
up and when i confronted ice poseidon
who's better known by his real name paul
de nino about this scam he was
shockingly honest you want to keep the
money that's not yours
that you took from the project even
though you'd failed to deliver i mean
i'm not really sure what you want me to
say but yeah i'm trying to like get you
to return the money because it's 100
still
available and you could do that yeah i
could give the money back it is within
my power um
but i'm gonna look out for myself and
not do that i i you know i don't like
know what else to say that's just the
most honest answer now these influencer
scams are becoming more and more common
in part because of how easy they are to
pull off ice poseidon's scheme
apparently took him only two weeks of
work to set up before he apparently got
bored with the project and decided to
stop working on it and just took the
money like seriously how long did you
work i'm just curious well like you said
it was a fork so a couple weeks couple
weeks three hundred thousand dollars
that's it's a nice chunk of change
now i pleaded with paul or ice poseidon
to return the money that he stole in
part appealing to the guilt that he was
taking money from his fans who were all
much worse off than him ice poseidon's
response was that he didn't like how
that made him sound i don't know if
you're aware of the fact that your
average fan has way less money than you
so you're just taking from poor people
like you understand that right
that is definitely not that that is not
a good way to put it that's a pretty
funny way to put it my dude it's uh it's
a pretty pretty thing to do from the
very beginning this story shocked me but
especially the twist at the end that i
can't tell you about yet but what i can
tell you is that this is my most
in-depth investigation yet into
influencer greed cryptocurrencies gone
wrong and the blockchain now i know it's
been a while so let me remind you this
is the 10 million dollar studio i'm your
host coffeezilla the internet detective
and well
it's good to be back
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in order to understand what happened
with ice beside we have to rewind the
clocks back the story started when ice
poseidon first got into crypto i invest
in a lot of the like [ __ ] coin like a
lot of the
you you put money in and then you sell
in like 20 minutes when it pumps ice
poseidon first got into crypto just
buying a lot of meme coins but like many
influencers he quickly realized gambling
on another person's coin is a suckers
game the fast easy money is actually in
getting other people to gamble on your
point now this moment is important it's
the moment ice poseidon realized what a
gold mine it could be to start his own
scam you're telling me i could create
a cx coin and then people could buy it
because i could say that the community
is super strong and then i could sell it
in 10 seconds and make 10 million
dollars what the [ __ ] am i doing ice
poseidon would later say that the clip
you just watched was a
joke and that the idea of him scamming
his fans was just a bit he played up for
the audience but that core idea that he
was missing out on a huge opportunity to
make a ton of money was real and it
nagged at him and pretty soon he decided
to start his own cxcoin is the one to
choose i'm the founder of cxcoin my name
is paul dino and i decided to make a
community driven token that i'm
personally going to be a part of now
almost immediately does got a lot of
attention obviously given his past
comments about sort of scamming people
people were understandably skeptical of
this and it came out right after save
the kids and you would have thought that
myself and other people like mudahar
would have talked about this whole thing
but heist poseidon was working
incredibly hard behind the scenes which
is something i need you guys to
understand he was contacting people like
myself and pleading with us that he was
just joking back then and he was serious
about this coin he wasn't about to pull
off a scam like save the kids he was
different he even mentioned in live
streams that save the kids was gonna
make what he was about to do much harder
i know about the facecoin steezy that's
why i'm trying my best to be as
transparent as possible i've been
working on this for like a month now and
i wasn't gonna let that drama stop me
but it definitely makes it a little bit
uh more difficult ice poseidon
repeatedly told skeptics that he
couldn't rug this coin if you wanted to
he had locked all his money up in a
smart contract he told me that in dms he
said don't worry no rug here all the
money is locked lol and look i have to
admit i was busy at the time with some
other investigations and
i gave him the benefit of the doubt
something that i obviously regret now
but periodically i would hear you know
complaints from his community that they
thought something was off but every time
i'd go to ice would immediately respond
immediately and he always gave me
something that sort of sounded
reasonable and i later learned he was
doing the same thing with everyone who
said something negative about cx coin in
fact he got a dextero article killed
about cx coin being a scam i mean i even
asked him about this at the time and he
said this the stero article went up and
then down did you see that yeah i
emailed dex proof i wasn't scamming so
leaving that up quoting a twitter with
two likes is a bit unfair to me the
point i'm trying to make is he was
playing the pr game hard telling
everybody he was different he even gave
me his wallet addresses and told me to
hold him accountable he wasn't gonna do
anything shady and everyone sort of felt
like okay maybe maybe he's doing
something different you know maybe
everything he's been saying was you know
just a joke
dude if i see it if i see a million
dollars i'm selling i don't give a [ __ ]
i'm not gonna be like i'll hold for you
guys bro i see a million dollars in my
portfolio i'm out not gonna lie that
looks bad but i'm gonna be really
generous here and give ice the benefit
of the doubt that clip probably was a
joke and it was probably made before he
was actually thinking about making cx
coin into a real thing now as time moved
on i and many other people sort of
forgot about cx coin until january when
i decided to take a break for a little
while and while i was off i couldn't
help but feel that there was something
else going on i just had a hunch i had
to look back so with my free time i
joined the cx coin telegram and started
tracing back the wallets that ice
poseidon had given me so transparently
and pretty soon i found out that well he
gave me the wrong crypto wallets whoops
he gave me the dx sale wallet instead of
his personal wallet which didn't tell me
anything for example one of those things
he didn't tell me was the fact that he
took out two hundred thousand dollars
from the liquidity pool at the very
beginning which is directly at odds with
what ice poseidon told me himself when i
asked he said don't worry all the money
is locked up except for two hundred
thousand dollars i guess but it also hit
another story which was the
misappropriation of the so-called
marketing wall now according to cx
coin's own white paper the marketing
wallet was to be used exclusively to
quote fund marketing campaigns in the
cryptocurrency market but in the
telegram there was another story going
on ice poseidon was complaining that he
had spent money on an ad campaign and it
just hadn't helped but we spent 53k on a
b talk and it hasn't really helped the
wallet is limited he berated people who
complained you want me to spend 30k on
stuff that doesn't help or you want me
to think about the best ways to use
marketing money exactly you can't use
the marketing money on well you know
marketing instead the money seemed to go
somewhere else shortly after this coin
launched ice poseidon bought himself a
brand new tesla this video was published
july 24th and as he says he bought it a
week ago putting it right around the
time that he launched the coin and
realized he had suddenly gotten a lot of
money to his name
but i'm sure all that money is locked up
right
apparently not and here's the
interesting thing the longer things went
on ice poseidon just sort of gotten more
and more brazen with the way he used the
money right at first it was just sort of
sitting around then he started sending
it to cash out wallets and eventually i
calculated that there's roughly a
quarter of a million dollars missing
from that marketing wallet but that's
not all ice poseidon had tricked his
followers at this point by getting them
to buy into a vision of a long-term
project the whole idea was that this was
going to be a donation platform for
streamers and that it would take a while
to build he kept reiterating this again
and again i mean this is a long-term
project i'm trying to you know we're
making a donation platform so i'm gonna
put that on my stream and this coin will
just
be around
for the entirety of my streams he said
this a lot in the telegram too you know
this is long term right thanks guys i
assume everyone is in it for the long
haul anyone who invests in something
should know this was a long-term project
so one week is not going to see results
now later i would find out this was a
lie ice poseidon did not see this as a
long-term project he actually gave up
after two weeks but i think i'm getting
a little ahead of myself the point is
ice was getting brazen he was
increasingly intolerant of people who
called him a scammer saying they just
hadn't done their research he even
brought my name into it saying he had
talked to coffeezilla maybe implying
that i had cleared him and i've talked
to these [ __ ] people
coffeezilla i've talked to these guys i
showed him i showed him the coin i
showed him everything and you know
they're giving me the benefit of the
doubt so obviously they would call me
out if it was a scam
i'm gonna be honest this really pissed
me off ice poseidon was using my name to
try to imply that he was legit when in
actuality he had just fed me false
information about his coin and begged me
not to talk about it but amazingly the
final piece of this puzzle wouldn't fall
into place until a few days ago as i
said ice had been getting more and more
bold thinking i guess that he had gotten
away with this and on january 22nd 2022
using his wallet that he didn't tell me
about he drained the liquidity pool
essentially killing his own coin and
taking the money from his investors to
be specific he drained about ninety
percent of the funds which is about
three hundred thousand dollars now for
important context liquidity pools are
how you get money out of crypto right
you can't just cash out a coin like
cxcoin right you can't buy groceries
with it someone has to be willing to
trade you that coin for something that
you know sort of has value so coins like
this rely on something called liquidity
pools a big sort of pot of money and
what ice poseidon did using the fact
that he created this coin he rug pulled
90 of that from his community which
meant that that's three hundred thousand
dollars that his investors would not be
able to get back out and at this point i
simply had had enough this was a scam he
had lied to me from the beginning and he
had lied to others about it and i wanted
to confront him but i couldn't let him
know that i knew anything otherwise he
wouldn't pick up the call so i simply
told him
i wanted to and to my surprise
he agreed and so on the 26th of january
we had the call you're about to see and
mind you i'm expecting him sort of to
deny everything like who would take
credit for this
well ice would i guess it looks like the
coin got rugged
you know anything about that i mean yeah
i mean not rugged but uh i mean well
someone pulled all the liquidity out
that's a that's a rug right that would
be a rug yes uh but
there is still liquidity in there 40k
got left and 300k got ripped out or
something like that
yeah i mean that is exactly what
happened right are you laughing i mean
is that funny
[Music]
i mean
no you're hearing this right he's
admitting he took out 90 of the money
but that's not a rug pull apparently he
had to do it after all the crypto
markets were crashing and if he didn't
take out the money who would the crypto
market is crashing and
300 000 isn't there there's two options
right leave the money in there and then
if bnb goes down it's like a hundred
dollars the money goes to
anyways or i could take it and the money
is not just going to dust
the money would have never gone to dust
i mean it just would go back to the
investors when they sold out when you
told them hey guys i'm no longer
interested in this project i wipe my
hands of it you know you got your 50k in
you got your 50k out you're good right
you didn't deliver this is not your
money i can't believe you keep thinking
of it as like as your money that's going
away that's your investor's money and it
should be their decision what they do
with it
okay i mean that's fair point that's a
fair point yet despite all these fair
points i kept making every time ice got
cornered about the fact that he was
basically stealing from his investors he
slowly pivoted his language from oh this
isn't a rug pool to more like well the
investors deserved it he said they
believed too much in his project and his
word like part of the responsibility is
on them as well for being you know like
putting too much emotion into it now
look i want to be clear i agree that
investing in any influence or coin is
idiotic but the logic here seems to be
insane they believed me so it's okay i
scammed them
i asked dice about this i don't know if
you're trying to say they deserve it
you're saying they don't owe some
responsibility i agree with some
responsibility but do they deserve to
get ripped off
no i mean nobody deserves that
it's just gonna happen though
like i said sometimes you have to look
out for yourself uh i don't really know
how else you want me to put it i mean if
you i mean you could say it in all these
different ways to make it sound as
horrible as possible and you know what i
can agree with you on some of those
things i just don't like to put it in
those specific ways because it makes it
sound like that was the intention from
the start which it wasn't and there it
is the final refuge of every scammer i
started with good intentions i meant to
do the right thing but i kept reminding
ice poseidon or paul or whatever like
these excuses made no sense because it
wasn't as if the money was gone it
wasn't as if it had vanished he still
had it and could return it at any point
he doesn't have to go down as the
scammer so i don't know why you're
acting like it has to end with like you
being the bad guy here that's not what
i'm trying to do at all i'm trying to
like get you to return the money because
it's 100 still
available and you could do that so
that's what i'm not understanding is i
want to get to that point i don't think
we're going to get there if you want the
answer uh
yeah i could give the money back it is
within my power um
but i'm going to look out for myself and
not do that i i you know i don't like
know what else to say that's just the
most honest answer now i do believe he's
being honest here i believe this is the
most mask off anybody's ever been on my
channel most of the time when you get
these guys on the phone they just try to
deflect and dodge i don't think that's
happening here isis being a hundred
percent transparent and i realized it
was a unique opportunity to get the full
story of how these scams work ice
poseidon proceeded to walk me through
the details on exactly how long it takes
to whip up an influence or scam like
this and the profits you can expect from
it can you tell me how much money you
made off this i'll just call it a scam i
know you don't want to call it a scam
but it is a scam so what did you make of
this well i got 55 and then 45 went to
uh my developers so i don't know
probably like 300 000 nice what it what
a good what a good profit from doing um
i mean how long did you work on this
project like seriously how long did you
work i'm just curious well like you said
it was a fork so a couple weeks what do
you plan to do with the money uh invest
into crypto ethereum mainly well there
you have it for two weeks of work
forking someone else's program you can
get 300 000
which annualized is a pay rate of 7.8
million dollars per year if he would
just scam every two weeks it's not hard
to see the appeal obviously but what
blew my mind is that he hadn't gotten
away with this like he got caught
red-handed and somehow i guess i was
just expecting him to go oh well okay i
guess i'll return the money now but no
he just kept doubling down you are
deciding to do the thing you know that
and you're still doubling down i am
doubling down do you not agree though
some of the responsibility is on people
who if you're still holding something
that's inactive for months like sure
okay maybe they you know have faith in
me whatever but that's not a good that's
your fans dude that's your fans these
are people who followed you since they
were kids they admire you they look up
to you
that's the people you're saying well
that's their fault i honestly couldn't
believe what he was saying here not not
that he didn't care you know i am kind
of used to that but he clearly expects
zero consequences for his actions right
and this made me think that at least
part of the reason for this might be
because stories like save the kids which
got huge press ultimately nothing
happened don't get me wrong it's
important to get these stories out there
anyway but you have to understand the
inner workings of the greedy influencer
when you don't have law enforcement
consequences for what is essentially
theft and fraud you end up with people
like ice poseidon realizing they can do
the same without consequence and i'm not
merely speculating here this clip you're
about to watch is of ice poseidon
discussing with his partner moises what
happened to sam pepper one of the
leaders of save the kid they don't talk
as if he's a cautionary tale but instead
as if sam pepper had won as if sam
pepper had beat the system he stole
money and he got away with it i mean i
did watch that coffee still video i
think sam's like a millionaire now
so i think he's i think he
still succeeded me although although he
he got it in a very poor way he made up
like abandoned bro sam's probably
nowhere like probably has like three
million crypto if the dude broke his
lease if you got a bra yeah tesla to do
paid
like what was it 10 stacks to break his
lease i don't know yeah if you're
breaking your lease and leaving the
country i mean you definitely
if he really felt the need to do all
that then he probably made plenty of
money
sam pepper scammed people but because he
did it without going to jail he's
successful he got away with it that's
how these people think so is it any
wonder when ice poseidon is caught also
stealing money his response is oh well
i'm just gonna look out for number one
it's their fault for getting scammed
they shouldn't have believed me he's
just so obviously not afraid of getting
caught and why would he in fact i asked
him about this fact whether these things
should be prosecuted and he seemed to
think that this was a wild idea do you
think the uh fbi should get involved
with cases like this or like the sec or
do you think like people like you should
be prosecuted
um
no i can't say this enough these guys
aren't scared they think they can do
whatever they want they'll just fork a
coin take 300 000 another 200 000
another 250k and walk away and screw you
what are you gonna do about it oh and by
the way in case you thought that this
was just a matter of ice beside messing
up once i actually found old clips of
him admitting to um what seems to be
some kind of credit card fishing scam i
fished credit cards back when i was
younger dude i didn't do anything
um with the credit cards because i
didn't i was like afraid of going to
jail but that time he didn't go through
with it because
he was afraid of the consequences well
that was then and this was now and now
he's not scared anymore ultimately this
whole conversation between me and ice
ended with us just sort of going in
circles me pointing out that what he was
doing was ethically wrong him telling me
that he agreed but he essentially
doesn't care and i felt sort of like a
failure afterwards to be honest um i
didn't achieve my goal of having ice
poseidon return the money to his victims
however a few hours afterwards ice
poseidon deemed me one last time he told
me he wasn't going to give all the money
back but he was planning to give a
little bit of it back 155 000. now i
want to be clear about this giving back
155 000
is better than nothing it's good for the
investors who hopefully will withdraw
their money as soon as watching this
video but it's so obviously a
last-minute hail mary for whatever is
left of his reputation it's kind of
pathetic i mean to be clear he's still
keeping the bulk of the money he knows
that and he knows that we know that
remember this still leaves him with
taking 200 000 from the project at the
start another quarter of a million
dollars from the marketing wallet which
went basically nowhere and then three
hundred thousand dollars from the
liquidity pool of which he's saying okay
i'll return 155 000 i don't know what
this is supposed to demonstrate are
people supposed to all of a sudden
applaud as he gives a small fraction of
what he took except wait a minute i just
checked ice poseidon doesn't even seem
like he can do that much after dming me
i went to the telegram and his admin
updated everyone and said we just
finished a buyback of over 120 b b
rocket emoji which is not 155 000
it's only 40 000
now whether ice poseidon has actual
plans to put the rest in or oh my gosh
return the full amount i really doubt it
it's just amazing to see that ice seems
to be doing this only because he got
caught sort of got interrogated for 30
minutes and faces reputational damage
yet he still can't muster the moral
courage or at least fear to return the
small fraction of money he promised and
so to close this look
i'll be honest in my opinion ice
poseidon is not a good person i don't
think he regrets anything or feels bad
about any of this and i think the
unfortunate conclusion many other
influencers will come to when looking at
this is that ice
like sam pepper has finally made it he's
succeeded in the influencer game he's
gotten away with it or has he there may
still be ways to prevent stuff like this
from happening there are two things you
can really do number one you can share
this video so more people become aware
of what ice did and get more eyeballs on
it but two if anyone was scammed by cx
coin and lost money they can report
their losses to
ic3.gov linked below this is the fbi
submission portal if you've been
defrauded or wrong and if enough people
report things like this there's a chance
people will be brought to justice i just
hope it happens sooner than later that
way i'll stop hearing about how
influencers like sam pepper
made it until then all i can do is
report dig and investigate that's all
for now i'm coffeezilla thanks for
watching